there. I don't think that this one works
because um there are different
coefficients,
right? Yeah. I don't know.
Um I don't know if this works because I
think they're different coefficients on
the reward.
Hard to say.
Guess we do a couple quick things on
meta.
Which of these policies is actually
uh which of these policies actually
matters?
I think that this is just a common
encoder is all we need for this.
Think the neural MMO 3 policy is good,
right?
Obs are not just one hot, he
says. Okay.
feature set encoders. This is so
freaking complicated.
almost. Oh, so I can probably just comp
this thing.
probably just calm this
thing. Let's just get the snake
policy. Basically, just the snake
policy.
does. And after this we'll have to do
normalization probably.
570k
train about the same as
That's should be able to do something
with this,
right? We can just normalize the data a
little bit.
Wait for this and then I'll uh have a
little model to
run. Nice and easy. Pure convolutional.
And then we'll see whether it's actually
all that hard to learn.
Not
bad. Good job, man. That's hilarious.
run this the main not in the
meanwhile. See if I totally broke it
with um the coms.
correctly.
255 100 100
100. There's seven of these. So, this is
three, four, five, six,
seven. Seven of
those. Wait. 1 2 3 4 5 6
16 I don't want to mess this up. Let me
just let me just write this out.
Now we're cooking with
uh what's the stupid expression? Now
we're cooking with
damn. Okay, let's do it like
this. And do it like this.
You should be able to compare this
one directly to the other
one. We will see.
We'll see whether that helps at all with
the
uh
optim. Looks like it might. This is
already higher.
helping. There we go.
I'll give this a minute to run and then
I'll send over these results and we'll
see what this does.
Uhoh. Well, we'll see if this hits a
capacity
issue. Looks like it
might, but only the encoder layer was
way wider.
or actually I think the thing that you
would change first is
64 here, wouldn't you?
There it goes. So, that's already a
little better than the uh the previous
up. And we'll just see how capacity is
compared to the original. Original was a
way larger net. So like we might have to
up the size a fair bit before we hit
that.
off.
Yeah. All right. Next up is going to be
This is like a reasonable model I would
say for like a
medium complexity problem. You got 256
hidden block
size, 128 stack of
coms. Should be decent enough.
Oh, yeah. And the baseline's only 0.1
and 100 mil. So, we're doing just fine
here.
400k 820,000 perm model. That's a pretty
decent size
model. I'd be surprised if the problem's
too hard for
that. Like you can do a lot with a model
that size.
What did they do for their uh their
trainer?
steps mini batch one up to
epoch. I mean those aren't horribly far
away from ours.
All our other prams are going to be
different,
I mean, this is these are such like a
different net size. We might have to
retune
I don't see anything in here that would
be
um anything in here that would be
screwy. This all seems reasonable to me.
bit. But uh I think that the best one
they linked to me
was they got like 0.5 in 400 million
steps.
I think that's with a bigger model as
well. We've done seven
minutes. No, it's about the same size
model, I guess. Same speed model at
least.
think there should be anything missing
from the
conf other than maybe the self features
would be
and we'll see how this does. This should
be better.
surprised if this is not like
immediately and massively
better. It's 11 by 11, right? So, isn't
five the middle one?
should
be. Oh yeah, there we
go. That's something.
I mean, we can easily sweep this now,
right?
I hope this is this looks like it's
better than the previous one. Yeah.
And we'll see if we get the plateau if
it gets to 0.4, which is the best on
this
result. So far, yes, he got to 2 at like
150.
I think he has a steeper slope on his
though,
maybe. Hard to
say. Is a pretty clean learning
curve. Actually, he is. That was with
smoothing. He does have it
higher. Oh, we'll
see. I don't I also don't know what
model this is with. I think this is with
like um comparably sized but different
architecture model.
It's a clean curve at the least. Okay,
let's uh let's commit this up.
no space left on device.
Really? Well, that's an interesting one.
it? Should be a buntu
mapper. Yep.
I'm blindly pasting these because I've
done this
before. It's just the same exact setup.
It's freaking
Wonder if that was screwing anything
up with the the previous
run. Could have been.
config. I hate
hydra. I don't know why people use
this. Failed to build
hydra. What Python are we on? 312.
I have this running on Python 312
though, don't I?
package. Well, that's not getting a a
sweep
then tonight. That's what you get for
using shitty config packages that don't
[ __ ] work.
obnoxious. It didn't work because the
config is
sweeps? Yeah. So, these are still
running, which is good.
wacky. Not that bad, though.
Not that
bad. Presumably, this is sweeping these
rewards as well.
this call copy these params in and run
it for a long Huh?
Funny that this sound like virtually
identical to the
original. These have been increased a
lot.
correctly. Copy the negative sign.
That's horid.
missed? Learning rate, gamma, lambda,
learning
rate. Think that's
everything. Oh, the betas obviously.
Okay. And then we have the other sweep
running which is
solid. Oh, we got a little bit of growth
there.
like we're stuck at
0.3. There might be some like semantic
meaning to that.
bad. I'll have to look at their
architecture and stuff,
but it's not like fully stuck at 3
either. It looks like it's still going
up just slowly.
That's kind of flattened
out. That is okay. There will be more
time tomorrow.
day. I'm trying to think if there's
anything else we can do to like make
sure the neural MMO stuff works well
overnight.
I think it is to be fair more likely at
this point.
Like if those hypers work so well on
just about
everything, it's probably just a matter
of like MUP for the learning
rate and
then getting the correct model size for
the problem.
is probably all it is to it. I mean,
that's what we'll do next, right? With
um some of these harder tasks we have
access to, it'll be worth getting up
working and worth be getting that
working with
Muan. We'll try a few other things as
well, I'm sure.
I mean, there are a couple remaining
hiccups with
um generalized advantage estimation that
we were still targeting, but I think
overall we should
be we should be pretty well
set. Let's take a quick look one more at
my
um MMO three runs.
so the magnitudes are clearly not
comparable
here. There's like a step change in it.
is very sort of
slow
learning. Let me go check the wi result
because I think we had a uh we have a
puffer wand result in
here. Let's look for
um so I mean here right this
This just took a while to take off
initially, didn't it? Like this part of
the curve. What is
this? So, the best one here is like 300
mil to get 1.05, I
believe. If we look at some of these.
Yeah, because I think these were
different maps. I think this is the new
map. So, like you're looking for
in 300 mil like only
1.05. How are we doing if uh if we take
that into
great. We're only at We're still under
1.01.
What hyper
prams did uh did we use for
this? I'm sure that I had them in the uh
the
previous version,
but we had these rewards,
right? And then
Big batch
size. Little bit of
entropy. Very weird
probably just a matter of running the uh
the sweeps
then there's no reason we shouldn't be
able to do um you know at least this
well we should be totally fine I think
we only had two M's as
well what was the training speed of
this did train at
500k which makes sense with that big
mini batch
size all right Well, I mean, I'm sure
we'll be able to get this if we want to
get to
params. I think we'll just let uh we'll
just let stuff run for
tonight and not worry too much about
it. Unless this thing has already
failed.
And I might want to run the original
config.
Honestly, maybe we go run the original
config. Night, man. See you
around. Thanks for stopping by.
Why don't we just do something like this
real
quick? Puffer box
4. It should be puffer box
zero, right?
Hey, start contributing to Puffer. It's
it's a great way to do some RL. And I
mean, this is really where this is where
RL is getting
solved. I mean, you see the progress
here. It's like this is where RL will be
solved.
People call them yolo runs when you just
change a bunch of [ __ ] based on your own
intuitions and uh try to just like make
something work.
I mean, we've kind of crushed all the
easier
ends as of
today. Little more than trial and
error. Little
more. Yeah. So, this is 4 m. So it's
nums is equal to
This is like the
originalish params with the new
optimizer and some of the nice new
goodies. And we'll see how this
works. Or it doesn't.
If a run like that works, do you ever
try to figure out why by looking at the
math? So, up until
today, it's just a bunch of nons. It was
just a bunch of nonsensical garbage
basically every time. Today is the first
day where the good uh params and the
good settings actually line up with what
you expect in RL
generally. Uh this was the major
breakthrough today.
RL is no longer
cursed. So really, this is
probably in terms of terms of just pure
capabilities, this is probably the
biggest single day advancement I've seen
since I started working on
Okay.
Well, that's about all I can do for
today. What do you do when they don't
line up? How do you debug something like
that? There are traces. Clear error
messages. Not in RL. There aren't
because there's no actual error in the
code, right? algorithm is implemented
correctly, right? The algorithm is
implemented
correctly. You've tested it against a
bunch of other stuff. You know how
hyperparameters are supposed to scale.
You know model size is supposed to
scale. You know all these things and
none of them actually happen or work the
way that you expect.
That has been the problem with RL more
than
anything because RL could since like
2017 RL could be made to work on
virtually any problem but it was always
like so janky and so difficult. So today
is the first day where it actually works
roughly out of the box on like a dozen
different
environments. Where do you go from
there? Pain and suffering and lots of
trial and error like guided by your
intuitions, right? and like by what
knowledge you have over how these things
are supposed to behave, but often you're
just wrong. And even like the best
person in the world in RL is going to
just be wrong cuz they just don't make
any bloody
sense. So today is the first day where
RL is not like
that. That's why this is such a big
deal.
There's still some small limitations,
but now we pretty much know what we have
to do. And the parts that like were
completely unexplainable
uh have now been explained and now
work. I mean, I said my goal for the
year, right, is we want to make RL 10
times easier to get up and running on a
new problem.
If we were like, you know, maybe we were
30% of the way there yesterday. Today
we're like 70% of the way
there. Where do you go from here?
There's still a few things that we need
to do. I think we need MUP so that uh
learning rate actually behaves the way
that we
expect. And then the new algorithm is
going to handle gamma and lambda being
weird and we should be
good. Do you build tools for easier
debugging more environments more? Well,
I mean, you see what I've done, right? I
said, "Okay, none of this stuff makes
any sense, and we're going to have to
run thousands of experiments to figure
it out." So, I made a bunch of
environments that run really, really,
really fast, right? Like, you know how
many experiments have taken me to get to
here? Here, these are all experiments
from 25,000 experiments from the last
like three months.
These are just like my personal
experiments for fiddling with
stuff.
like I don't know order of like 10
trillion steps worth of experiments.
So the data scale that's involved here
to make this stuff work, uh, this right
here would be like without puffer libs
environments, this would be like a,000
GPU years worth of compute or
more, probably a lot
more. So that's how we got here, right?
We made a bunch of environments. We made
them really fast. We use the
environments to figure out what the heck
is
wrong since Puffer lo. Yeah, the
environments are
fast. So, we run more
experiments. Of course, our trainer is
also
faster. We've kind of optimized the full
stack.
I mean, you can see what these are as
well because they're
grouped. So, most of these are like
groups of 200 experiment hyperparam
sweeps. So, it's not just 25
experiments,
uh, 25,000 experiments. It's groups of
like a couple
hundred intelligently optimized
experiments using methods I developed
that didn't exist
before. So, it's been this whole massive
massive process to get
here. But
now we have uh RL just working out of
the box on
all the M's in puffer with the exception
of a couple tweaks being needed for
neural MMO which we're doing right now
because that M's are really really
hard. But yeah, this is this was the
goal with Puffer, right? We've got a few
things left, a few things that are still
one thing that's pretty easy and one
thing that's pretty hard, I think.
Um, and then we just kind of got RL
working and we'll see where we go from
there. I think I'm going to want to take
this stuff and like throw it on, you
know, hard RL problems in
industry. Um, we're going to make some
really awesome
demos. We're going to release some
really clean and really fast tools.
We'll see from there.
Uh bet it's currently the there's a dev
branch in puffer tank that we were
using. Wasn't Puffer's goal to make a
framework to make RL I wouldn't say
framework but yes the goal was to make
RL advancements easier. Here you
go.
Right. Tools. Yeah. Lighter weight
tools.
It's hardly a framework when you have
like a single file trainer,
right? There's
like probably like three or four times
more code in the environments versus the
uh the rest of puffer lip together.
Like with all the newest environments
being PR, it'll be about 30,000 lines of
environments and maybe like a few
thousand poor lines of uh of Python that
we're actually
using. Yeah, framework's bad.
Framework's never good.
I really don't like big clunky heavily
abstracted stuff, especially not in
anywhere. So, neural MMO 3 is going to
be the real
test. Neural MMO 3 is
hard. We should be able to beat the
previous baseline, but then we'll see
where we go from there.
If I were an undergrad, I'd be I would
so just puffer live.
Yeah. Well, just contribute,
right? Come build some cool
stuff. Yeah. I mean, I I usually stream
all day Saturday. So, if you get
stuck, I usually I stream all day s
Saturday and then Sunday I like go and
do a bunch of exercise and like not code
a
ton. Job search
sucks. Job search is
rough. But hey, you know, our best
contributors are people here that have
came in with zero RL experience.
So you can kind of do a lot of stuff
quite quickly
now. Awesome. Look forward to
it. There's really not that much uh
puffer lip specific to learn cuz like
it's really a thin piece of software.
The dev branch has some clunk to it just
because like you know there are flags
for all the new like algorithmic tidbits
that we're testing. But generally puffer
is really
thin. There's not a ton to learn. RL
generally yeah there's a fair bit to
learn but not puffer
lib. It's just CMS with some RL Python
algos. It's just CMS with
uh there's one very nice like few
hundred line piece of code that does
very fast multipprocessing and then
there's one like
roughly,500ish line piece of code that
is our entire algorithm and trainer
implementation. That is
it. Sython's just like a trivial little
binding to
see. That's all there is.
You know, we have some other tools for
nonpuffer ends if you want to wrap third
party stuff quickly, but generally
that's all it
is. I mean, there are a few nice things
I came up with, right, to make this
fast. Like the C writes uh the C code
writes observations directly into shared
memory buffers that are in contiguous
memory.
But I have all that set up for you and
it's very easy to use. And the actual
thing that implements it is like a few
dozen lines of code. You just kind of
have to understand it
all. We're very much looking for new
contributors, by the way. Like the way
it works around here, and I think you've
seen if you've been on uh many of these
streams, right, is anybody who actually
puts effort into like building M's,
helping with buffer lip, uh I put effort
back into them, you
know, you know, the people who've been
building M. I code review every single
line of the contributions. We go through
I try to share some like insights on how
to think about RL and try to get people
doing stuff that will help them learn
and push puffer
forward. Jose painstakingly put this
together. Yeah, I'm a little tiny bit
um I'm a bit pigantic on trying to keep
the code like brain dead
simple, but that's about it. It's like
if anybody uses like any remotely fancy
abstractions, I'm just like get that out
of
here. This code should be brain dead
simple. But hey, you know, there's a
reason for it. No
decorators. I think we have a couple at
property decorators and that's about it,
honestly.
I mean, we don't
have I think there's like one place I
couldn't get away from having an
inherited class, but other than that,
like very like try to not
object-orient like functional dog. It's
just like brain dead simple code on
data. That's the
goal. No mixins. [ __ ] that.
But, you know, I get on people's case
over dumb stuff, right? Like, I don't
let people use double pointers. Like, I
don't let people do like double
pointers. I don't let people be um doing
even freaking union types most of the
time. Um, what
else? What are the other ones? Oh, yeah.
No dynamic memory allocation. Screw
that. Like, it's just very, very simple
code. It's like look, you write if
statements, you write some loops, you
write some assignments. That's all you
need. You don't believe me? Look at the
neural MMO code. That's all I
use. Oh yeah, and don't write too many
damn functions.
Sometimes you need dynamic outlets, but
like I think there's maybe two places
total uh that we needed them in the
environments that we have. I think I
needed them in neural MMO just for the
map generation because the maps can be
like 4096 x
4096. Ah yeah, but you introduced an
arena, right? And now you have this
other abstraction. It's like you don't
need the dynamic Alex most of the time.
Believe me. What we actually do is we
allocate a lot of memory from Python
because it needs to be a shared buffer
anyways. You'll
see there is still a little bit of
boiler plate which I'm not happy
with. Like the boiler plate's mostly
because you have to go it's not because
of the C. It's because you have to go
through Syon to get to Python. So, you
know, there's a little bit of boiler
plate associated with uh going from C to
Syon to Python, but it's not
bad and it's like really really easy and
self-explanatory.
figure Python types can be used function
args. No, actually that's the one thing
that Sython does for us. But the problem
with Python is you kind of have to redo
the whole
header. Like you have it, you already
have the def the function definitions in
um in C, but then Syon makes you redo a
header anyways. And then like you know
you have your step method in C and you
have your step method in Syon and you
have your step method in Python. So it's
a little
stupid but um that's more of like a
language interoperability limitation
than anything. That's kind of the worst
bit at the
moment. Nothing else is really a
problem. The one other thing is like you
know it's designed to work in pure C but
also in Python. So like Python is going
to pass you your observation buffers and
then you're just going to init whatever
other variables you need. But if you're
going to try to like demo the envure C
which is how we run it on the website uh
then you need to allocate your own
buffer. So there are two different init
functions. One for allocate your
yourself and the other for pass in
pre-allocated. And the other thing which
is not which is not hard but is actually
really cool is we have our own neural
net library in pure C that we use for
the web
demos. It's like I don't know I was
pretty proud of
this. It's just really simple. There's a
pufferet.h. So this is less than 600
lines of real code. No backward pass
just forward mode for um for web demos.
So you see like it's like here's a
matrix multiply. Here's with
accumulation. Here's a 2D
conf. I don't actually use that arena
actually. I was playing with it but I
didn't. We don't actually use
it. Here's an LSTM. So this is a this
function right here. This is an LSTM and
C,
right? It's really
simple. Making the com sim. I mean, we
could. You'd also want to tile it and
stuff. Um, the only thing that it would
kind of do is maybe let us run slightly
larger networks on our web demos though
because like all of these are running in
C and they like they already work,
right? This is the neural MMO policy,
you know, this is the breakout
policy little triad.
Like these are all just running train
neural nets. And
see some of them are super human. It's
pretty
This was kind of funny because um see I
gave bet this project thinking it was a
lot simpler than it
is. So like Bet is still pretty new and
was even newer when I gave him this
project to programming in general. So I
kind of gave him like too big of a
project but he did it
anyways. At first, like the first time
he did it with like two to three times
too much code, but he paired it down and
now it's pretty
decent. Yeah. Well, I mean, bet you
should see some of the [ __ ] that I wrote
when I was new. I've written some like
ridiculously over verbose
code. Like I've written some truly awful
things.
my I think I probably do have this on my
uh on my GitHub.
This was an early attempt at neural MMO
before I knew what the hell I was
doing. Do you guys type in?
Nope. I actually that's a pet peeve of
mine. I hate typed
Python. The reason being that the types
are not actually enforced.
Python. The thing is that people think
that they're enforced and they're not.
Oh yeah, this thing. This is a Panda's
3D visualizer I wrote uh I wrote this
the week I discovered Monster Energy in
college. I think this was like two
nights up until 4 in the morning to make
this thing work.
Yeah, I think I had a screenshot in my
defense of
this. Okay, so welcome everyone.
There were a lot of systems in here. So
this is the super early screenshot from
open
AI discover built this
in
that. So this early version of neural
combat
screen by continuing to make the
problemer.
So if we could figure out how to fix
that, then I think you'd probably be
able to get cooperation before
cooperation with all the new mechanics
on reasonably small scale. And after
that, you need more game mechanics.
Well, okay. Um,
it. Basically, I interviewed there to
build neural
old. So this is like some of the
oldest. This was like when I was just
like using really crappy genetic
algorithms on stuff.
Here it
is. This is the uh I remember exactly
where I was when I built this. I was in
a hotel with my family on Thanksgiving
break. I just discovered monster and was
downing like two or three of them a
day and I wrote this like shitty
Minecraft knockoff client
um in Pandas
3D. It ran like 15 fps, but it ran and I
was like trying to get agents to run
around and learn how to cut down trees.
You can see like the awful terrain gen.
It's This is literally like breath first
search filling in diamonds with
different
squares. You see this like terrible ore
generation at the
bottom. But yeah, this is this is the
second time I tried neural MMO. I don't
think I have code from before this, but
there was even an earlier version of
this when I tried to do this when I was
even younger and knew even less than
this. This was
probably if you look at the code, the
code is awful, but this was like kind of
the first time. So, I started coding at
14, right? And then like that project
there, that's probably the most complex
thing that I'd built up until that time.
So I was I think
19. I was probably 19 at the time. 18 or
19. So it
took a good four years of like
continuous programming before I could
like kind of do a small project even if
I was making a total mess of
it. And then I'd
say another four
years. Is it another four years? No,
another two years before I was writing
code that was better than the majority
of
researchers, which is a very low bar.
two years after that for like doing
competent
midscale projects like you know sort of
middle stage versions of neural MMO 2 or
neural MMO one
rather and then the
last over the last few years really
being able to build
whatever in the last year in particular
I've actually gotten I think I've gotten
at least twice as good at what I do just
in the last year alone
mainly just from having the freedom to
like do stuff the way I want without the
academic constraints, you
know. But hey, I guess this is supposed
to be kind of motivational in the sense
that it takes some time. It takes some
hard work. But hey, if any of you folks
want to get into RL and want to help me
build some awesome stuff, Discord's
open. Come drop by.
Yeah, it's
been it's been a pretty singular focus
and star puffer li on GitHub. That
actually does help us a lot. Sometimes
the star chart figure breaks, but here
it
is.
1779. That's pretty damn good for an RL
library. That's like one of the bigger
ones at this point.
It's funny how whenever I start talking
about stuff like this you like the
viewer count just pops up on YouTube and
Twitch. Hi
folks. Do you think we've gotten any
cool experiments done in the meantime?
Well, I've been
reminiscing. Yeah, I mean there are a
few. It's very hard to learn this
end. It was very
hard. Does this
work? Oh, this does work. This one works
though. These are the original params
that we tuned for uh for neural
MMO. So this
is 1.15 at a
billion. What was the
original? Yeah, it works. So it does
train
doesn't train as well as this
though. Wait, hang
on. Something seems weird to me. This is
a 10 billion
Three. This is the run right here. I was
looking at the wrong
one. See there? This one actually has
1.4 at 1
is by modern standards. There's some
needs some work. What's the reward for
neural MMO? Well, this is the new neural
MMO, which is actually kind of kind of
complicated, right? And there's no
population
size. Oops.
So, this is this game right
here. And uh it's kind of
big. And this isn't even the fullsize
map. This is just the one that we throw
on the
web. But these are enemies. They come in
different levels. All these are
different items you can collect with
different
tools. This is running. Yeah, this is
running in my client right here in my
browser on one core.
though. It's only running a few neural
nets cuz the uh the network
implementation isn't optimized. So, the
red ones are hostile NPCs. This is a
neural net. Now, this guy doesn't seem
to be doing anything because the
policyy's not amazing. It will just stop
doing stuff for a while. But, if an
enemy comes over, it will like run away
from the enemy and start doing stuff
again.
You context switch between NPCs. You can
just scroll around. Here's an NPC.
Here's an NPC.
Right? You can play this on the website.
If you just hit control, you'll see
it'll stop. And now this is me
playing. And I can like move this guy
around and like I can go find an enemy
that I think he can beat. for
instance. Let me see if I can find He
can't win against any of these
guys. Okay, he can beat this level one
if he's if he's
smart. So
here there, this is no longer me
playing. And he just he misguided that
one by one hit. So we
lost. Uh the NPCs are not controlled by
neural nets. The players are controlled
by neural
maps. The NPCs have like basic path
finding and like basic scripted AI. Uh
these guys are controlled by neural nets
and they don't look like much, but if
you watch them for long enough, they
will actually do some pretty impressive
stuff. It's just like they don't really
have any motivation to do it. So,
they'll kind of just wander around for a
bit. But, if you watch these guys for
long enough, they will actually like get
a whole bunch of levels, collect and
equip a bunch of different items, avoid
some enemies reasonably well. Um, like
they actually learn a lot of interesting
stuff if you watch them for long enough.
Now, my goal with this now that we've
made the algorithm so much better is to
get some like really impressive policies
on neural MMO 3. I think that would be
fun because this is really like way more
complex of an end than pretty much
everything else out
there. Is it super complicated? It's not
super complicated. I think it has like
four components right now. So, I'll show
you how I I deal with it.
It's like really easy to make these.
So, they get a reward every time they
level up in combat. They get a reward
every time they level up uh a
profession. They get a reward for
getting better quality
items. There's a reward for using the
market, which is currently set to zero.
And there's a reward for dying. I don't
set these coefficients manually. I sweep
over these. I treat these as
hyperparameters and optimize them with
the hyperparam sweep
algo. So you see I don't actually have
to know how important each of these are.
I just had to pick like five important
things in the environment. So I just
picked five important things. I added
them into the reward code and then I let
the uh the hyperparam sweep optimize the
coefficients. Pretty cool, right?
This is the sweep config and it just
sweeps over
Maybe this ends up doing better. We'll
see longer
term. It's cool though either
way. Swap the neuronetypers.
Yep, we
did. And it was actually very fiddly to
get the uh the original policies to
work. But here's the thing. As of today,
we now have roughly one set of
hyperparameters that works for every
single environment in Puffer Lib except
neural
MMO. Neural MMO is the hard
one, but I'm guessing that we probably
only have to fiddle a couple we only
have to fiddle with a couple of those
hyperparameters to get neural MMO to
work as well. It's going to be my
guess and we're going to understand why.
That's going to be the next
thing. This is the major breakthrough
today. Right before today, every single
environment needed like a 200 parameter,
a 200 experiment hyperparameter sweep to
even do something remotely
reasonable. Now we have one set of
hypers, pretty much one set of hypers.
Couple small tweaks. It didn't take very
long at all. Solves everything.
does better than the original
hyperparameters in the majority of the
environments and does at least
reasonably well in the
rest. I checked all the
MS. I did check all the
cool.
Well, it depends which parameters change
in neural MMO,
right? If the batch size changes a
little bit, that's
understandable, right? If we just need
to increase the mini batch size for
example, okay, you know, a neural MMO is
a hard M. There's too much variance to
do small mini batches on neural
MMO. If we have to change the learning
rate, that's also understandable. It's a
larger network than uh in the other MS.
Larger networks need lower learning
rates, at least if you're not using
MUP, which we don't have integrated yet.
Now, if everything needs to be changed,
yeah, then there's an
issue. But the ones that I will say I'm
a little suspicious of, this gamma and
lambda, I have a separate effort to
delete
these. The other algorithm I've been
working on, if it works, it will delete
these two parameters
entirely. So, there is good stuff
coming. Definitely good stuff coming.
go back to work. See you this Saturday.
Sounds good. I think I'm going to go to
bed. Uh I'm going to go to bed and get
started first thing in the morning.
Well, after I run in the
morning. So, for folks watching, all my
stuff's here. Puffer.ai. I it's all open
source including all the new
advancements there in
dev. You want to support the project for
free? Start the
repository. You work at a company and
you want to get the latest in
reinforcement learning working directly
on your stuff and want to get my eyes on
your
project. Check out our service tab. We
do offer support contracts.
Other than that, you can join the
Discord to get involved with
development and you can follow me on X
for more reinforcement learning content.